the machines on Alessandra Melnick's
farm are almost 40 years old it's with
these he works the land about a hundred
hectares south of Kiev the size of his
land makes his one of the smaller farms
his machines often break down making his
work more difficult and inefficient
loans from banks all they want to take
up to 28 percent Interest
that's just not viable on top of that
they want to take 3 times the value for
security but here the ground belongs to
the state despite farmers financial
problems German machine builders like
Roper and Horsch are enjoying healthy
sales last year Horst sold more than 20
million euros worth of soil making
machines their customers agricultural
firms working on between 1020 thousand
hectares they can afford to invest with
their incoming revenue mostly for the
desert back mom
you can split farmers into two groups a
younger generation and an older which
lived through the communist period the
new farmers understand finance and
economics better
- of Nicosia as well as the new
agricultural technology if he knows who
I know but I know economy but I know
different with each new Ukrainian
companies often prefer to buy from
abroad such as this specialist machine
imported from Germany it opens up and
fertilizes the soil at the same time
hoping to keep the ground damp
that was decisive for farmer Alexander
kasnian who works 3500 hectares
he says it's raining less and less in
central Ukraine and the topsoil is only
fertile when it's damp it's been
emissions antonetti you want it climate
change is palpable in central Ukraine we
used to have a forestry steppe climate
but now there's predominantly just the
dry steppe climate that's threatening
our economic development that's why we
need the technology to keep the water in
the ground but I never wore him the EU
has made 400 million euros and loans
available for Ukrainian agriculture but
weather smallholders like alessandria
are set to benefit remains to be seen at
59 years he feels too old to get into
debt even if the loans got cheaper